hey this is presh talwalkar
this problem appeared on the harvard
admissions test in 1869
a man bought a watch a chain and a
locket for 216
the watch and lock it together cost
three times as much as the chain
and the chain and lock it together cost
half as much as the watch
what was the price of each
problems like this are actually quite
popular on the internet
in that spirit here is the same problem
presented in pictures
can you figure out the price of the
watch the chain and the locket
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
so here are the first two equations
the second equation tells us that the
sum of the watch
and the locket is equal to three times
the chain
the first equation also has the sum of
the watch and the locket so we can
substitute in that the sum of those is
equal to three times the chain
we then add the value of the chain so
our first equation becomes three chains
plus one chain is equal to two hundred
and sixteen
so we have four chains being equal to
two hundred sixteen
so one chain will be one-fourth of that
which is equal
to fifty-four
we can now use this value into our
second and third equations
our second equation says the watch and
the lock is equal to three times the
chain
this will be three times 54 which is
162.
our next equation says two chains and
two lockets is equal to a watch
two chains is equal to two times
fifty-four which is equal to a hundred
and eight
the second equation here
gives the value of the watch in terms of
the locket
so we can substitute that into the first
equation
so we have
and
108
plus
two lockets
plus one more locket is equal to 162.
we'll now just focus on this last
equation
we have 108 plus three lockets is equal
to 162.
so that means three lockets is equal to
162 minus 108 which is 54.
and therefore one lock it is equal to
one third of that which is eighteen
so we've solved for the chain
and the lock it
we now have to solve for the value of
the watch
but we know all three items together add
up to 216.
so we can substitute in our values for
the chain and the lock it
we then could solve for the watch as
equal to 216 minus 54 minus 18
therefore the value of the watch is
equal to 144
and that is the answer
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description